-It's great to see you, buddy.
-It's lovely to see you.
-In person. It's not on Zoom.
-Yes.
-Yeah, do you like the Zoom?
-Although, Ariana looked
really beautiful on Zoom.
-Yes. She's just gorgeous, yeah.
-She was amazing.
-Are you Zooming?
-I've been Zooming a lot.
I guess it's helped us.
It's helped us through
this whole crazy time.
-It's been wild.
-I have a few things coming out.
I've been doing some press
recently on Zoom.
And it's funny because when you
are Zooming from home, you know,
some of your home life
gets in there.
And I was working from
my girlfriend's place,
and she has two lovely children,
and her 8-year-old son
kind of snuck in the room
at the end of my Zoom interview.
And the journalist was saying,
"Well, it's -- you know,
you've been working for a long
time and you're the youngest
Academy Award winner to win
an Academy Award
for 'The Pianist.'"
And I see him start
jumping around.
And I say, "Yes, thank you."
And then he's freaking out
in the corner of the room.
And then we wrapped up
the interview and he goes,
"Your penis?!"
[ Laughter ]
"Your penis? You won an
Academy Award for your penis?!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
I said,
"No, that wasn't a category."
[ Laughter ]
-"I'm just happy
to be nominated." Yeah.
-It is the youngest.
[ Laughter ]
-That's right. You actually won.
That's hilarious.
How old are you? Twenty--
-Now? I was 29.
-29 to win an Academy -- you're
the -- and I think you still are
the youngest actor
to win Best Actor.
Congratulations on that.
-Yeah, thank you.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-When did you know you wanted to
get into acting?
Were you a teenager?
-I mean, I love acting.
And I guess I started acting
really young.
I think before acting, I had --
I really was infatuated with
magic.
-Yeah, me too.
-Yeah?
Did you stud--
Like, I studied magic and I --
-I used to check out books
at the library. Magic books.
-Yeah. Magic books and I'd learn
routines and I'd go to Tannen's.
There's a great magic store in
New York that I used to go to.
Try and con them to sell me
flash paper, which is, like,
super flammable
and burn your house down.
You know?
But I started at six years old.
I was, like, infatuated with
magic.
And by the time I was 11,
I was doing
children's birthday parties
who were a little younger,
and I was the "Amazing Adrien."
-Wow!
[ Cheers ]
Wow!
-For 50 bucks, I could have done
the whole party and --
-Started working young.
-Was working. Yeah.
-That's fantastic.
Do you remember
any of the tricks?
-Yeah. I mean, I haven't done
much in a long time, but yeah.
-Could you do a trick?
-You want me to do
something like --
-Could you do a trick now?
-I could do, like,
a party trick.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This was, like,
when I was six though.
-Okay. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-It's not quite great.
Are you game?
I need some tissues
or something,
just in case you or I
start crying.
[ Laughter ]
-I have tissues.
-Good. Alright.
-Do you want the whole box?
-I'll do it.
No, tissues are cool.
-Are we doing the trick?
-Couple boxes.
Yeah, we're doing the trick.
We're doing the trick.
-This is fantastic.
Alright, I just want to make
sure I'm doing it right.
-So you just settle down
right here, alright?
[ Laughter ]
So, really, we'll get
the whole box of tissues.
So...
♪♪
Magic music.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, exactly.
-I like that, yeah.
-You never thought you'd get
magic music, but yeah.
-So, basically, you know, so
much of it is about, you know,
keeping your eye on
what you are doing.
So if I put this is in this hand
or this hand,
which hand would it be in?
-Be in this hand.
-Right. Or this one.
I'll show you again.
-Wow! Wait, wait, wait.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Very simple.
We can stop. We can one-up it.
Now we have three of them.
It's hard sometimes because you
have to put it in there first,
but if you put it in this --
This one or this one?
[ Laughter ]
-This one.
-Oh.
-Yeah.
What is going on?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wait, do I, like, have a brain
of a 6-year-old?
Is that what you're doing
right now?
-No, I just have it in there.
-Alright, yeah, you got the
thing. You put it in your hand.
-But everybody has to keep
their eyes on it, yeah.
-Everyone can --
-I put it there.
This one or that one?
[ Laughter ]
-I'm going to say --
-That one.
-Okay, wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Ah, I still got it.
-That's not bad. Not too shabby.
That was fantastic.
-That was pretty good.
-Thank you for doing that.
-It's good at a party
when everyone is really wasted.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
And then you went from
performing there
to becoming an actor.
You got the bug.
I was going to say you're great
in all your films,
but I really love --
you and Wes Anderson
work fantastic together.
This is your fourth film
with Wes.
I think you just did your fifth
film with Wes Anderson.
You guys just have a thing
and you're fantastic in it.
-Yeah, I'm really grateful
for it. Thank you.
And he's just such
a wonderful -- he's a genius.
And "The French Dispatch,"
which is out now,
is just such an amazing movie.
It's a privilege working
with him.
-Do you have any memories of
Wes where you go like...
-I mean, I have so many, like,
life experiences with Wes.
We shot a movie.
My first film that
I worked with him
was "The Darjeeling Unlimited,"
and we were India.
-Yeah, of course.
-And I got to be brothers with
Jason Schwartzman
and Owen Wilson.
-Fantastic.
-And we shot on a moving train,
and it was really
an amazing time.
And I bought a Royal Enfield
motorcycle,
which is a really cool,
old British bike
that's built in India,
and I was planning to ship it
home after shooting there.
-Yeah.
-And one day I was riding
and we were on the highway.
I'm riding and there were
all these tuk-tuks,
these auto-rickshaws.
They're like carts, but they
were -- Those were the taxis.
-Yes.
-They're little carts.
And they were on a highway.
I'm jamming behind this guy.
And he veers left at full speed,
and right in front of him
is a cow walking away from me
on the highway.
And so I jam on the brakes
and I'm literally skidding,
about to rear-end the rear end
of a cow with my face.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
-And I was laughing as -- I was
laughing because I was like,
"This is how they're all
going to remember me."
[ Laughter ]
I really -- I had --
It was like a near-death
experience,
and I was like
[ Imitates brakes ]
There it was. There it was.
It was a --
-There it was.
-There it was. Sorry.
-There -- There it was.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow.
-He's waiting to find it.
-Wow! Wow!
-I had to do it. Sorry.
-Wow. There it was. Oh, my God.
Wow. Okay. I get it.
-You know what's crazy?
It's a little tangent, but,
like, I was just talking with
your producer and I was saying,
"Yeah, you know?"
They were like,
"Oh, you used to do magic."
I said, "Yeah, I'd love to do --
I'd love to, you know,
do a trick."
And he said, "Well, maybe you
can do one with Jimmy."
And I was visiting my mom.
And my mom overheard just part
of the conversation.
We got off the phone, and she
goes, "So it's great.
You're going to do a -- You're
going to do Jimmy's party?"
And she thought somehow now,
someone was going to pay me
to do a birthday party.
And I was on the phone
with a parent,
and the rest of the discussion
was more like peripheral,
working a lot with
Wes Anderson.
-Yeah, then you're like, "Yeah,
but I'm also not giving --
I'm not giving, but I'm gonna
play this little boy's party."
[ Laughter ]
-It is your birthday.
Every night is your birthday.
-You're the best for doing that.
Thank you. I appreciate that.
How do you --
[ Applause ]
That was actually great.
How do you describe
"The French Dispatch"?
And who do you play?
-Yeah, it's a -- It's so fun.
It really is several vignettes,
several stories that are
through the eyes of
the journalists working at
"The French Dispatch,"
which is an American publication
that's based in France.
And it's wonderful
and all these stories.
Our story is with Benicio
Del Toro and Lea Seydoux.
And he plays an artist,
and I meet him in prison.
And I become a pretty remarkable
art dealer, and I sell his work.
-Yes, exactly right.
I want to show everybody a clip.
It's also, by the way, just
a beautiful film as well.
-Isn't it beautiful? Yeah.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Adrien Brody
in "The French Dispatch."
Take a look at this.
-We're done with flowers
and footballs.
We're finished with beaches
and seascapes.
We're getting out of armored
rugs and tapestries too.
I found something new.
-Modern art?
-Modern art, our specialty
starting now.
-I don't get it.
-Of course you don't.
-Am I too old?
-Of course you are.
-Why is this good?
-It isn't good.
Wrong idea.
-That's no answer.
-My point.
You see the girl in it?
-No.
-Trust me. She's there.
-That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Adrien Brody, everybody.
"The French Dispatch"
is in theaters now.